shoes make me feel like I can predict
the future so do things that I know that
I should or want to do but sometimes
they don't have the guts do
at the moment I'm dreaming a lot about
travels normally traveling alone I don't
know what else says about me but I like
to travel to places I've never thin in
realized apparently the last dream I can
remember I was buying a vintage coat and
a little vintage shop and I found a
ticket in the pocket and it belonged to
Queen Anne London life I dream of the
great outdoors a lot nature and swimming
in the sea and walking through forests
shopping and styling new clothes that I
don't even own yet
[Music]
I think where dreams come from my
subconscious spirits from a lot of
holding on
maybe it's giving you signs maybe it's
my alter ego
I would describe my dreams with the
color yellow I think it's a very
harmonious color it's very neutral nudes
pinks lots of past early colors the
nicest dream I can remember is swimming
in the sea and the Sun was on the water
and it's all crystally and sparkly and I
could feel like the Sun on my skin
my dream actually have never taken me
anywhere that I don't think exists on
the planet the world we live in is such
a magical place
I don't really dream of anywhere else my
dreams do take me so imaginary world
sometimes but they're really hard to
describe I think I watched too much game
firms because they're so imaginary
actually put words into what they are
because they're not tangible real things
in our tangible material world if I can
soundtrack my dreams actually I would
say that it would either be classical
music like a huh oh it would be really
grimy like drum and bass
my dreams definitely do affect my mood
when you get up and the item that you
bought in your dream is not on your
closet it makes getting dressed
that morning really really difficult if
it's been an amazing dream I'm like god
I don't want to come out of it
I want to stay in it yes I definitely
think I can achieve my dreams I've
already achieved a whole lot of my
dreams
my dream for the future is happiness
peacefulness and a really big boat
I'm starting to dream about designing
instead of buying playing and making
mistakes and joy is such an important
part of our lives and so many of us are
consumed with being perfect so I want to
help people to learn how not to be
perfect anymore
[Music]
dream is the new fragrance by ghosts
find out more at gross fragrances calm